and i thought well this is crazy
i can't i can't i can't do this michelle
obama is sharing her experiences with
menopause
i experienced the night sweats even in
my 30s
the former first lady got candid on the
most recent episode of her new podcast
the michelle obama podcast
michelle opened up about the many
challenging symptoms she endured during
her time
in the white house and when you think of
the other symptoms
that come along just hot flashes i mean
i had a few before i started taking
hormones
i remember having one on marine one
i'm dressed i need to get out walk
into an event and literally
it was like somebody put a furnace in my
core and turned it on high
and then everything started melting and
i thought well this is crazy
i can't i can't i can't do this
she also revealed how husband former
president barack obama
responded to her health issues as well
as several other women he worked
alongside
barack was surrounded by women in his
cabinet many going through
menopause and he could see it he could
see it in somebody because sweat would
start pouring and he's like
what's going on you know and it's like
no this is just how we live
you know he didn't fall apart because he
found out there were
several women in his staff that were
going through menopause it was just sort
of like oh we'll turn the air
conditioner on
and michelle didn't mince words when she
talked about how men would fare if they
faced the same experience
how many men do you think could deal
with the the severest form of cramps
which
literally feels like a knife being
stabbed and
turned when you think of all that a
woman's body
has to do over the course of her
lifetime
going from being prepared to give birth
to actually giving birth and then having
that whole reproductive system shut down
in menopause
there is power in that well one of the
things we
a phrase we coined when we got here was
we want the white house to be the
people's house to really be the people's
house
during the final year of brock's
presidency michelle told e.t
about wanting to continue being a
positive influence after
leaving the white house i mean we're
going to keep doing this kind of work i
mean the beauty of
there's a platform as the former
president and first lady which is a
beautiful thing in this country
so it's not like we're going to stop
living and doing the things that we feel
are important mentoring young people
working on girls education continuing to
make sure
people lead healthy lives but this is a
very unique and rare platform
and you don't take it for granted and
it's it's been an honor
to serve this nation and we hope we made
people proud
in in the process